so one thing that's become like my main
thing you you were sitting on the panel
on Real Time with Bill Maher yeah when
Sam Harris was on we had so much fun
with Ben Affleck I'm assuming most of
you guys are probably familiar with what
happened but basically that was so much
yeah I mean you saw to me what became a
seminal moment and a split in the in the
Liberals between the progressives and
what I considered the true liberals
which is where I fall right but
basically but basically Sam Harris said
a few things about the difference
between Islam and légion Harris was
making a an intellectual argument based
in research-based pupils he was killed
balls and things like that so that
that's so that's the jump off point Ben
was making a progressive argument that
again going back to the the point I was
making before about people and how those
pupils and all those numbers actually
translate into people so when you start
talking about people then you're talking
about attitudes and perceptions and all
of that and it was a very interesting
dynamic or I thought so for the people
that didn't see it basically Sam quoted
a couple polls and then immediately Ben
Affleck he screamed that's gross that's
race that's racist and then that changes
the dynamic the next day every media
outlet the question was you know Ben
Affleck calls Bill Maher and Sam Harris
races suddenly the onus was on them to
prove that they weren't racist so for
you I assume when someone throws around
you know be racist or bigoted I assume
you don't take those things lightly what
was it like to be sitting there in the
midst of that a special because because
you weren't even you guys weren't even
supposed to be involved in the
conversation right what that was that
was all yeah that was the bill and Sam
moment yeah and I saw Ben lean in and I
went all hell we go and then he started
and I've learned over these years that
when two liberals are going at it there
is no
no need for the conservative to opine or
contribute in any way yeah
and now say much United right I stopped
trying in a little dislike yeah you guys
worked that out let me know yeah um but
what do I take away from my take away
from it was I understand what I when I
did speak what I was trying what I try
to get on the table was you're both
right and you're both reflecting exactly
what's going on in the broader
population that we we see these these
numbers that reflect some some events or
what's going on we look at extreme
actions by an extreme group of people
and we pejoratively project it over
everybody in that particular class of
people so you had this dynamic even
though you after the ten wasn't really
doing no you when the message the
message right right that no Sam was not
doing that and that Sam was just you
know just looking at these are the
numbers this is what this is reflecting
this is what people are saying these or
this is what the poll says but this is
again a speaks to the dynamic of our
politics of of we immediately go to the
personal it became it became intensely
personal when you label the charge you
throw out the charge you're racist yeah
or you even infer that that that's an
intensely personal moment in that
conversation in which when it comes my
way all bets are off because it's your
acid me now this is this is one-on-one
look I've been called an Uncle Tom I've
had Oreo cookies thrown at me I've gone
through this I know what this this
ugliness of in politics is about and
even more broadly and so I thought Sam
did did very well to hold to hold it and
keep it from moving into the intensely
personal but Ben was intensely personal
and that's because he cared passionately
and I think it speaks to you can have
that passion but you need to know where
the limits are you need to know where
the limits are in the conversation and
you need to know how to conduct that
passion in a way that your point is not
lost because it
is still and I thought he made a valid
point and we're so good you don't want
to project this pejorative view about a
race of people about a class of people
about any individual in a way and you
certainly don't want to use statistics
in numbers to do that I take great
exception to the fact that whenever
anyone starts talking about poverty why
do you immediately jump to black why is
the image that pops in your head when
someone mentions poverty in this country
is the image of a black person when is
when you when you talk about crime in
this country the criminal element you
know crime is why do you jump to my
community yeah we saw recently even on
the welfare question some members of
Congress get into trouble because they
were inferring that the folk you know
you know we're going to solve welfare by
you know working in the black book do
you know the majority people and welfare
in this country or white have you been
to Appalachia mmm-hmm seriously because
that's those people are hurting mm-hmm
they don't live in an urban inner city
why why why is their pain and their
suffering and their poverty less
important for focus and emphasis
particularly when they're part of the
majority no so that's sort of the Dean
so that's the danger that's the danger
when you start prioritizing and start
speaking about a group of people in a
way in which you clearly don't know what
you're talking about now because you're
not reflecting what's really going on I
live in one of the wealthiest black
kunti wealthiest black county in the
country period so when you start talking
about poverty that's a whole different
conversation when you come to where I
live so you can't paint that you can't
use that brush the same way you use it
when you're talking about the folks
somewhere so that's the problem people
get into when they start doing doing
that that sort of you know stereotyped
conversation about white folks black
folks poor folks rich folks yeah all
right well they gave me the rap thing
here so last thing I'm putting on the
spot why don't you jump back into
politics because I've sat here with you
and exactly the reverse of what I saw
with Scott Walker
really
I know you you believe in what you're
saying I may not agree with you on
everything but you get the system and
I'll get back in I you know I I like
where I am right now because I get to
get up every day and have a nice cup of
coffee and ask myself who should I piss
off today yeah and I don't have to have
a meeting after I do that so I you know
I kind of liked the space I love the
National Dialogue I want to be a part of
the National Dialogue as you are and I
think that that's that's a good space
right now as long as you know I'm able
to do it I appreciate MSNBC for giving
this conservative voice an opportunity
to kind of come out and say you know
with my buddy Chris Matthews okay Chris
hold on just a sec can I talk now can I
get it yeah so but he's baiting as much
as it appears when he the last fight
that day I love hardball is a great show
is a great political discussion and it
is a very smart guy and it's very smart
intelligent conversation and we need a
lot more of that in our politics yeah
well I hope you guys appreciate what I
think is this heart about thank you and
thank you for that really appreciate